-Finally, guys,
we have exactly 11 shows left
before we go
on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for 12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters.
♪ 12 days of Christmas
sweaters ♪
♪ 11 days left ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right.
Every show between now
and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a bodacious
Christmas sweater
from the countdown
to Christmas cabinet.
Since there are 11 shows left,
let's open door number 11.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's nice.
Thank you very much.
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number.
I need you to jump up
and let me know where you are
if you get --
if I say your number.
Quest,
can I get a drum roll, please?
Who wants me
to pick their number?
This is good.
♪♪
-448.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright. Oh, man.
Here we go.
We can do a little --
Come over here. Gosh.
How are you? Barely made it
on the standby line there, huh?
Uh, you don't want to come down
one step towards me? Come on.
Gosh, I just walked up --
How you doing?
-Hi. Hi, I'm Mark.
-Oh, what is --
-What is your name?
-Mark.
-Yeah. Uh, Mark,
where are you from?
-I'm from Spain.
-Hey.
Welcome.
Thank you for being here.
Mark, it gets a little chilly
sometimes in Spain, correct?
-Yeah. It is.
-Yeah. Cold.
Right? I mean, you have this.
This is very nice.
I love this fleece.
Whatever it is, it's gorgeous.
Do you have anything like this?
-No, I don't, I don't, I don't.
-Have you ever seen
anything like this?
-No.
-No, never.
Would you like to try it on?
-Yeah, sure.
-Yeah, I think you should.
You can put it over that.
I want to make it
as uncomfortable as possible.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
And this is the front.
This is the front, I think.
The good thing
about this sweater
is there's no front or back.
You just put it on and hope
for the best, you know?
Oh, this is great, Mark.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. That's right.
Oh, wow. He made it through.
He made it through.
Look at that.
That looks fantastic.
Look at how good you look.
Fantastic, buddy.
-Thank you.
-Welcome.
Thank you for being here. Enjoy.
Happy holidays, buddy.
-Thank you.
-Give it up for Mark, everybody.
Stick around.
When we come back,
we're doing something fun
with Anne Hathaway.